it's a new mode of Transport in
lebanon's impoverished North
a new reality in a country where nearly
80 percent of people are poor
duct talks are becoming more popular as
the High Cost of Living changes the way
of life
has become very difficult so we are
always looking for ways to save money
and it's half the price to use tuk-toks
instead of cars
already vulnerable the global rise in
food and fuel prices has worsened
lebanon's situation
politicians blame for decades of
corruption and mismanagement are failing
to agree on a recovery plan
for most of lebanon's people life has
changed basic necessities are
unaffordable especially since the cash
strapped state and its subsidies on
basic Goods
in a country that Imports nearly
everything food price inflation is among
the highest in the world people's diets
have changed
we used to sell between 200 to 300
chickens a day now we sell about 50.
sales have been affected across the
board with the vegetables or even
clothes
bread a main staple is six times more
expensive as production costs spiral
power Cuts last most of the day not
everyone can afford diesel for private
generators others switch to wood stoves
since a gas cylinder costs half of the
minimum monthly wage
are returning to all Traditions but we
have to use wood because we are affected
by the fuel and electricity crisis
Millions like Rami awake can't rely on
their savings because banks have locked
depositors from their dollar accounts or
funds they can access are worth less
that's why the local currency the Lira
devalued against the dollar by more than
19 percent
I used to get paid 13 and a half dollars
an hour we had a good life we used to
afford to eat at restaurants now my pay
is worth less than two dollars an hour
we can't even attend funerals because we
can't afford transportation
the crisis has pushed the middle class
into poverty and as long as politicians
refuse steps to make the economy viable
again it's likely to sink even deeper
North Lebanon